Christie is in Indianapolis hi Christie
how are you hi thanks for taking my call
sure what's up my husband met a career
change he went from 20 years in the auto
sales management industry and switched
over to our B sales and is in a you know
base by base plus Commission pay scale
or you know pay range and it is now
March so he's been in this for about
three months and we you know we change
over our 401 K from his last company and
we had a three months well we had it you
know some savings that we used from that
401 K just to get us by the you know the
pay change no and you're kidding you you
cashed out your 401 K oh hey Barry no
only a few like a few thousand dollars
and then we left the rest and you know
then we just transferred the rest o into
a fund yeah we took like I want to say
maybe five thousand dollars out of that
and then just reinvested it in other
file I didn't why did he take this job
if he's gonna make less money well
because he was about the company who's
working for is not a very good company
they were trying to wedge it not even
though he was a very successful
individual very you know he has
integrity matters to him and it doesn't
to them and so he needed to get out
because he was it was going downhill so
he went from making a hundred thousand
five thousand dollars to make a move
well we know that was several years ago
the past few years it's been going down
and down it down with this company so he
you know we switched so we have that
money is still invested and he has about
hundred twenty-five thousand dollars in
the 401 K currently you know being in
sorry being invested yeah so then so
right now we're trying to figure out as
we've been in this house and we're
paying you know right now he's only
making four hundred a week with this
particular company and then plus you
know commissions on top of that
but it's just taking you know a while to
you know to raise that up but in the
meantime I don't you know we're kind of
it should remove because we have about a
hundred thousand dollars of equity in
our homes and you know if we moved to
you know better suit our budget but then
he has a new career so is he gonna be
able to get well we could be able to get
approved for a mortgage so far he
doesn't have in their career so far he's
made a bad move well if I made a hundred
grand he's not going to continue at four
hundred dollars a week
no he's a for another base is on top no
no $1 a week I'm sorry alright so twenty
thousand dollars a year I got that
that's the base but in many commissions
how long has he been doing it 90 days
so far he's starving right so his income
comes up or he changes jobs again not
okay you don't sell your house and
justify a twenty thousand dollar income
when you're capable of making a hundred
you go make a hundred right that's what
he's trying to do in this industry it's
just no taking longer I'm not sure this
industry mate he switched industries
right in that industry but it was not
going anywhere because the credibility
factor his company where he was put him
in a difficult position and they didn't
do what they should have done difficult
situation and it lasted too long it was
three years too long and Tom's value you
know he thought he was doing the right
thing he prayed about it this is worth
got this is very thought I've been
pleading him to and so now here's the
thing you cannot you cannot fix an
income problem by selling off assets
because eventually you run out assets
well so we have to fix the income
problem we don't sell the house
regardless of the story of how we got
here that's where we end up so hope that
helps thanks for the call